and lindsey graham is joining us now so
senator uh you
were uh had to run a uh a crowd there in
the russell rotunda as you were getting
uh to the uh the microphone there but we
uh we do thank you for joining us so
just if you could expand a little more
on what you told
sean hannity last night about senate
minority leader mitch mcconnell and your
potential support for him the next time
he runs for leader
well number one i think senator
mcconnell has been one of the best
republican leaders in the history of our
party but elections are about the future
not the past
mitch worked with president trump to get
a bunch of judges on the court he fought
like a tiger for the three supreme court
justices that were
supported by president trump we got the
tax cut so mitch mcconnell has a lot to
be proud of
here's my concern
if he runs great
no matter who runs
you got to prove to me that you can work
with president trump
because he's the most consequential
republican in the party by a mile
the american first agenda is very
popular with independents and
republicans
so all i'm saying is i like mitch a lot
he has a lot to be proud of but if you
want to be a leader in 2022 i expect
president trump to run again for
president you don't have to agree with
everything president trump does or says
i don't but you got to have a working
relationship because our party will not
uh do as well as we could or should if
we don't have a team approach from 2022
to 2024 where the house and the senate
republicans are working with
an american first agenda agenda led by
president trump so it's really common
sense what i'm saying and maybe that
relationship can be paired repaired i
hope so
senator some may hear you say that and
hear your warning last night
and think are you looking too far beyond
midterm elections
does it help right now to be taking
shots within your own party rather than
just rolling out the welcome mat after
losing the presidency and obviously
controlling congress
no i didn't i wasn't the one saying that
i'm going to run for majority leader in
2022. i'm okay
with focusing on taking back the senate
majority
i am like all in for that
president trump is indispensable to us
when it comes to taking back the senate
mitch mcconnell is raising a lot of
money he will be indispensable for the
republicans to take back the united
states senate in 2022. what brought this
up
is that senator
mcconnell who i respect and like and has
a lot to be proud of says he would seek
another term as leader and all i'm
saying is when we get to 2022
what i'm looking for is somebody that
can work with the most powerful
republican
in america and that's donald trump why
is he so powerful
people like what he did on our side as
president and a lot of independents are
learning every day how important it was
to have president trump to be our
president if you're pro-life there's
never been a better republican president
on the pro-life issue than donald trump
if you believe in a strong military we
had it he took the fight to the
terrorists we had
borders that were secure we had
a growing economy he did the vaccines
that saved millions of lives for covet
so that's why so many people like
president trump to my republican
colleagues you ask me all the time go
down to merlot and see if you can get
him to let go of some of the 2020 issues
i think that's not an unreasonable thing
to ask of him and me but to my
republican colleagues this is a two-way
street i think we need to understand and
give credit to president trump for being
the most consequential republican
president since ronald reagan you know
senator graham you said something very
key there a moment ago you said if they
can repair the relationship i i think
another question to ask is do they want
to repair the relationship big point of
departure between mitch mcconnell and
donald trump was over january the 6th
the minority leader gave a very strong
speech on the senate floor uh and and he
doesn't seem to want to have too much of
a relationship with president trump
president trump has called mitch
mcconnell a lot of names including old
crow now that said mitch mcconnell is an
astute politician and you know he knows
how to build bridges when necessary so i
mean when push comes to shove do you
think they're going to want to repair
the relationship i think it's in
everybody's interest to be a team i
think the american first agenda works i
think the joe biden's been a
fair as a president and is there for the
taking but i'm not dr phil
you know it's my job it's not my job to
fix every problem that we have nor is it
any other senator's job i'm making an
observation if you don't understand what
i'm saying i think you're missing the
point
on the republican side
you don't have to agree with trump what
he did in syria i didn't like i've had
my differences with president trump but
i appreciate what he did
and the media tries to divide us all the
time january 6 was a dark day in
american history but it wasn't pearl
harbor it's not 9 11. and that's all
they got to talk about so to my
republican colleagues let's spend our
time growing the party and realize that
president trump
is the most consequential
republican in the country since ronald
reagan and see if we can work together
whether or not they can repair the
relationship is up to them not me i hope
so
senator you wouldn't be saying any of
this unless you believe donald trump was
the future
of your party
he can actually
win you're so smart we know you're well
enough is that is that it
uh in case you missed the last four
minutes that's it
yes
i mean i'm just speaking i mean it's
like the sun comes up in the east
uh and it sets in the west 70 of our
party would like to see president trump
run again i would like to see him run
again i'd like to see him change his
behavior somewhat i'd like to see him to
focus more on election reform and talk
about how we can repair the damage
created by joe biden those are all
legitimate concerns but president trump
has unfinished business i think he's the
best person in the republican party to
take the calls take up the the banner in
2024 because unlike lindsey graham mitch
mcconnell or anybody else he actually
was president and when he was president
your life was better we were more
prosperous and we were safer so yeah i
think he's going to run if there's any
doubt i think it will be it will go away
fairly soon here just stay tuned what do
you think what do you mean you think you
wouldn't be saying this unless i think
he's gonna run yeah i think he's gonna
run i'll let him speak for himself but
you have to be deaf dumb and blind not
to see what's going on around here the
guy's got a hundred million dollars in
the bank
uh he has
wide support of the republican party and
a lot of people believe that the
american first agenda was good for the
party good for the country so i expect
him to run into my republican colleagues
i will do my best to try to help
president trump stay focused on messages
good for us all but this is a two-way
street
yeah you know senator you and i have had
this discussion in the past you you are
more optimistic about his chances of
running than others that i have spoken
with but uh you do talk to him i'll take
bets if anybody wants to bet
go to lindsey graham.com to place
hey we've got some breaking news here
uh this
this is coming in and we want you to
react to this a split decision at the
supreme court over the vaccine mandate
the supreme court has let
let stay the stay
that would have required
large companies to implement vaccine
mandates or testing but
federally funded health care centers
that employ health care workers they
have to adhere to the mandate so again
the mandate will not go into effect
against private companies it will go
into effect against federally funded
healthcare
companies
and facilities senator your reaction to
this
there's some symmetry to that that where
the federal government has a dominant
role i mean you know requiring mandates
for for the military i'm not so sure
that's the best idea but that's
certainly more in the rim of the
executive branch this idea of mandating
to the entire country without congress
being on board to the private sector the
court is going to shoot down so uh you
know the court has got a lot of good
conservatives on it thank you president
trump thank you mitch mcconnell uh 2024
be here before you know it but if we
don't win in 2022
john uh shame on us they're trying to
give us the election let's take it and
to my republican colleagues uh the best
way to win the house and the senate is
to be a team and if we win in 2022 we
got to stay a team and the captain of
the team is donald trump whether you
like it or not
i i sorry to dwell on it but senator
that goes back to the initial point i
mean
you said it
when you go back to the warning to mitch
mcconnell
why would you do that in this moment in
a midterm election year
as i said earlier rather than just
rolling out
i am it's not a warning i'm asking for
the meaning behind your warning it's not
a warning he says he wants to be the
republican leader i've acknowledged he's
been the most consequential republican
leader of my lifetime he's done so much
i mean bob dole was great but look what
mitch accomplished working with donald
trump the question is how do we go for
it as a party
the republican leader the senate and the
house
you don't need to kiss donald trump's
ass but you got to have a working
relationship with him for us to be
successful so the bottom line here is if
you don't have a working relationship
with president trump as a senate leader
or house leader that hurts us all
that's not rocket science do you have
any reason to believe that do you have
any reason to believe they can't mend
their relationship
i don't know it's up to them i hope they
can it'd be good i like mitch fine i
think he's done a done a great job as i
said but you know like it or not
the leader of the republican party
nationally is donald trump and nothing's
going to change unless something comes
out of left field what you saw today in
the in the senate democratic party that
makes perfect sense to me that joe biden
would push for a change in the
filibuster to keep from being run out of
town by the left it makes perfect sense
to me that a handful of people in red
and purple states would stand up to him
this is good politics for both sides on
the democratic side what's good politics
for republicans to work with president
trump you don't have to agree with
everything he does but have a working
relationship well senator if your
relationship with president trump is
indicative of anything it is possible to
bury the hatchet i remember a time when
he was so damn mad at you he gave him my
god
i've come to like him and he likes him
so that brings us together all right
well you have a share of the love of
golf all right senator always great to
see you thank you thank you bye-bye
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else